THINKPAD DOMINATION
Do you know what the best selling electronic
of all time is? Well if you guessed the iPhone or
the Samsung Galaxy, then you’re probably right,
but that’s not all that surprising. iPhones and
Galaxies are basically ubiquitous around the world
having sold billions of units. But something that
might be surprising is how many Thinkpads Lenovo
has managed to sell. Over the years, Lenovo
has sold a whopping 200 million Thinkpads. For
perspective, that makes Lenovo the world's largest
PC maker by unit sales, a title that they’ve held
on and off for decades. And what makes this
achievement even more impressive is that Lenovo
breaks basically every rule you can think of with
the Thinkpad. For starters, the Thinkpad doesn’t
look all that impressive. It’s not the sleekest
laptop or thinnest laptop like Apple is trying to
create. Nor is it the bulkiest and most overkill
laptop like Asus is trying to create. Heck,
Thinkpads still have those red TrackPoints in the
middle of the keyboard as if we’re living in the
early 2000s. In fact, Lenovo hasn’t really changed
the design all that much since the Thinkpad was
introduced way back in 1993. Yet, none of
this has stopped the Thinkpad because while
the Thinkpad might not be the coolest laptop, it
does exactly what it promises. It’s practical,
functional, reliable, and offers phenomenal
value. From a grounded perspective, these are
exactly what any consumer should be looking for.
But as we’ve seen with the smartphone market,
this doesn’t always hold up. In fact, some of the
worst selling smartphones are the most practical
smartphones like the Google Pixel and HTC
smartphones. Meanwhile, people tend to buy iPhones
year after year even if nothing changes simply
because the iPhone branding and marketing are
so powerful. Yet, within the laptop market, Lenovo
has been able to rise above all the hype and carve
out a massive segment for themselves. In fact,
many would argue that if you want all the perks of
a Macbook without the Apple tax or Apple’s antics,
you get a Thinkpad. So, here’s the story of one
of the last practical electronics that’s still
killing it in the year 2024: the Lenovo Thinkpad.
UNPARALLELED EFFICIENCY:
Taking a look back, the story of Lenovo
takes us back to November 1, 1984 to a group of
Chinese engineers led by Liu Chuanzhi and Danny
Lui. Originally, the company was called “Legend”
and the team was focused on importing TVs,
but after this effort fell flat, Legend would
pivot to the rapidly growing PC market. This
wasn’t all that easy either. Legend didn’t exactly
have the technical knowhow or resources to bring a
PC to market and scale production. As such, they
opted to fulfill background functions with the
market. For example, they started off as a quality
checker for existing computer brands. They would
also go on to create a circuit board that allowed
IBM compatible PCs to process Chinese characters.
But while these efforts were enough to run a small
local business, Liu had much bigger ambitions
for Legend. And to even have a chance at those
ambitions, Liu first had to hire a much bigger and
knowledgeable team that could handle a task that
was as daunting as bringing a PC to market. As
such, in May of 1988, Liu would pull the trigger
and place a job ad on the front page of China
Youth News. They only had enough money to hire 16
people but given the novelty of the PC industry,
Legend would receive an unprecedented number
of applications. 500 to be precise for a no
name computer company doing quality checks.
Liu decided to take advantage of the interest
and move forward with as many applicants as
possible. 280 would be given a written tests,
120 would be interviewed in person, and 58 would
be given offers even though they could only afford
16. And before they knew it, they would end up
with a staff including 18 people with graduate
degrees, 37 people with undergraduate degrees,
and 3 students. One of these hires was a man
named Yang Yuanqing who would go on to be the
CEO of Lenovo but that was still a long ways
away. In the meantime, Legend had to figure
out how to support a workforce they couldn’t
afford. This mainly consisted of taking on a
bunch of debt and living on scraps. In fact,
money was so tight that Liu and his coworkers
wouldn’t even take cheap public transportation,
opting to walk everywhere. But, from Liu’s
perspective, this was all more than worth it
because he was spending all of this money
on engineering talent and R&D, not flashy
office buildings or corporate retreats. And that
brings us into really the key advantage of Lenovo:
unparalleled efficiency. Lenovo is able to
run a leaner and cheaper business than even
most of their Chinese counterparts. And when
we’re talking about an industry such as PCs
which have been largely commoditized over the
past few decades, this is critical. In fact,
the average net margin for computers and
peripherals currently stands at just 3.42%. So,
coming out on top in this cutthroat market
is very much a test of efficiency and grit,
an area in which Lenovo has largely excelled. In
fact, Lenovo regularly boasts net margins that
are far slimmer than even 3.42%. They usually
hover somewhere around just 1.5%. So, if you’ve
ever wondered how Lenovo is able to offer such
value packed devices, well there’s your answer.
All the money you’re spending is directly going to
just R&D and parts. Virtually none of it goes into
fancy redesigns or advertising efforts. In fact,
even today, Lenovo only spends $100 million per
year on advertising. For perspective, Dell spends
over 10 times that every single year. This tunnel
visioned focus of cutting costs everywhere except
for where they really matter is what has allowed
Lenovo to launch such value packed computers
which brings into the company’s first computer.
MAKING A NAME:
Starting in 1990, Legend would begin
manufacturing and selling their own computers.
One of their biggest hits early on was the KT8920
mainframe computer. A lot of their models from
the 1990s were rather tacky and had odd quirks
but back in the day, people loved these quirks.
For example, in their 1998 Tianxi computer, Legend
included a physical button who’s whole purpose
was to just connect the computer to the internet
and open the default web browser. Obviously,
such buttons seem rather out of place in 2024,
but back in the 1990s, people loved it. Most
of Legend’s consumers were first time consumer
buyers and having a dedicated button to access
the internet was extremely helpful. In fact, the
Tianxi would go on to be the best selling computer
in Chinese history at the time, selling 1,000,000
units in 2000 alone. Such successes allowed Legend
to crawl out of their debt hole from the late 80s
and even host a successful IPO, but they never
forgot about their roots and what actually made
them successful. And as such, they would pour
all of their profits into improving production
standards and R&D which would eventually allow
them to launch their first laptop in 1996. By the
end of the 1990s, Legend would become a household
name, controlling 43% of the Chinese market. But,
outside of China, Legend was a nobody which
brings us into the Thinkpad. At this point,
most people wouldn’t bat an eye if you said that
Lenovo created the Thinkpad given that Lenovo and
Thinkpad have been synonymous for so long now,
but the Thinkpad wasn’t Lenovo’s creation. It
was actually IBM’s creation. Shifting back
to the early 1990s, Toshiba and Compaq had
come out with portable computers that they called
notebooks and IBM wanted a piece of the pie. So,
they would deploy their vast international
resources to create a competing notebook that
they would brand with their famous slogan “THINK”.
IBM would launch the ThinkPad in October of 1992,
and it was a great capable portable computer but
it was by no means sales driver largely due to
price. The original ThinkPad for example started
at $2,750 which is the same $5,700 today. And
it went up to $4,800 or $10,000 today. As such,
the Thinkpad really only appealed to businesses,
universities, and the government. Fun fact, in
1998, the ThinkPad would become the first computer
to be certified for use on the ISS, and to this
day, it is still the only computer that’s allowed
on the ISS. But aside from this fun fact, the
ThinkPad didn’t really have much else going for
it. At the end of the day, it was a niche highly
priced product that was completely out of reach
for the average person, but that’s exactly how
IBM liked it. They didn’t want to get into the
trenches and compete in a cutthroat market. They
simply weren’t all that good at that. In fact,
that’s why they got crushed in the PC market
despite pioneering the way. They simply weren’t
able to compete against cheaper alternatives
from Dell, HP, and Compaq. Laptops, however,
were a high margin industry where the excelled,
wait nevermind, that didn’t last forever. By the
turn of the century, laptops would also become
a highly competitive industry with low margins.
And by the end of 2004, IBM wanted no part of
it. So, they would decide to sell ThinkPad to
one of their largest suppliers, Legend, for $1.75
billion. From Legend’s perspective, this was their
golden opportunity to make an international
name for themselves. So, they wouldn’t waste
anytime in rebranding themselves as Lenovo and
kickstarting a whole new era for the ThinkPad.
MARKET DOMINATION:
Lenovo’s approach to ThinkPad
was pretty simply and straightforward. The game
plan was to simply apply Lenovo’s unparalleled
efficiency to the laptop market while retaining
all of the best features of IBM. For example,
Lenovo very much adopted the transparency of
IBM. Now of course, you could argue that IBM
isn’t all the transparent to begin with but
for Chinese standards, Lenovo made massive
strides forward. For instance, Lenovo adopted the
American standard of releasing quarterly financial
reports even though they were only required to
report twice a year back home. They also created
committees for audits and compensation. And Lenovo
even go on to host the first investor relations
conference in mainland China. But, not only was
Lenovo go on to impress investors but they also
impressed a lot of computer enthusiasts who
swear by the ThinkPad. From their perspective,
the ThinkPad was a no brainer. You basically
got a workhorse computer that used to be a
status symbol amongst business users for an
affordable price thanks to Lenovo. Since then,
the status of ThinkPads have very much worn off
but the practicality hasn’t. While the rest of
the PC industry has trended towards “the Apple
Way”, producing computers that look sleek but
are a nightmare to repair or upgrade, Lenovo
has stuck to their tried and true approach:
essentially producing a no thrills, pro consumer
MacBook. Now of course, this doesn’t appeal to
everyone, but for the people it does appeal
to, they would choose nothing else. Over time,
Lenovo has tried to apply this approach to
other industries like the smartphone industry.
For example, they bought Motorola from Google for
$2.91 billion in 2014 in an effort to break into
the smartphone market. But, Lenovo would figure
out the hard way that smartphones are still very
much a status symbol. And even someone like
Google isn’t able to carve out market share
using a practical phone. But, while smartphones
didn’t work out in their favor, Lenovo has managed
to find success in other no thrills industries
like the server market. In 2014, for example,
Lenovo would purchase yet another IBM business,
their server business for $2.3 billion. And today,
Lenovo stands as the 4th largest server maker
in the world controlling 6.2% of the market. All
of this has allowed Lenovo to grow to as much as
$70 billion per year in revenue. For perspective,
that makes them a top 200 company in terms of
revenue. Given their meager profit margins though,
this doesn’t even translate to $1 billion worth of
profit today, but hey is that really something to
complain about? After all, that’s what makes
Lenovo the last practical electronics maker.
While Lenovo has managed to maintain large demand
in the modern era, the same cannot be said about
other practical electronics makers like Sony and
Panasonic. Check out this video to learn more.